angela what's going on uh my question
is how best to handle
alcohol in the house and personal
consumption
when i've got a relative of my son
who is an alcoholic coming or to visit
for a whole week
huh that's a great question so tell me
about your son
uh he's 29 he
well he tells me we have a good
relationship we talk every sunday he
tells me
he's an alcoholic he knows he's an
alcoholic and he's not willing to do
anything about it um i enabled him for
way too many years and the path of least
resistance was
then to move in with his alcoholic
father my ex-husband
he's a good he's a good kid and he's not
figured out
what he needs to do with his life yet
and he's kind of just
i'm waiting for him to wake up but it
hasn't happened yet but i love him and
he's coming for a week and i want to see
him and i want to make sure
that we have a great time and i've
always got
a few bottles of liquor here in the
house but i feel like while he's
here i we probably should put them away
and not drink ourselves yeah so the way
you've painted that picture
the only responsible caring thing to do
in that set of circumstances
is to get every shred of alcohol out of
your house and to let him know before he
comes
that there will be no hock on the house
and it won't be welcome in your house
yeah and anything short of that is you
putting him in a position to fail
yeah you know we're we live smack in the
middle of a downtown
area where he can walk to a bar in three
minutes
right and here's here's the other
another thing
you know as well as i do if he goes out
to a bar
within if you know and i don't even know
if they're allowed to go to bars in
seattle right now if he does go to a bar
and gets all tanked up and then comes
back to your house
you're not going to have a good week
because that'll burn that night and
you'll be stressing it'll burn
all the next day because he'll be
hungover and not feeling well you'll
feel ashamed he'll feel shame there'll
be a whole mess and so setting some
boundaries now
that not only includes you letting him
know i'm getting rid of all the alcohol
out of the house we're going to have an
alcohol-free week
but also you cannot come to my house
drunk
is yep washington state is the bars
are going to be closed that's right
through through uh
the well into december so that's
actually i had
i hadn't thought about that um so can he
can he
go a week without drinking
uh i i don't know if he's a true
alcoholic he might not be able to and so
a whole week at your house may be a long
time
and as much as you want him there you
have to do the hard hard work
of letting that fantasy of your little
boy coming for a week
and having a lovely remember the times
thanksgiving
that's not gonna happen if he is a true
functioning alcoholic
there's gonna be some challenges that
week right
and i don't want you to set yourself up
for heartbreak or set him up for failure
right and so maybe it's a three-day trip
or maybe it's a
48-hour trip yeah
yeah i have no idea of knowing how it
might go sideways but i hear you what
does are
you are you remarried yes what does your
husband think about him coming to visit
oh he's fine with that he's as my
husband always says
we're rooting for him we want him to
succeed you know we
um and we talked about this and we we we
definitely both agree not having alcohol
in the house is the right thing to do
and not drinking that week ourselves is
the right thing to do
because we do love him and my my
new husband loves him i mean he's you
know
he's we want to help him so we don't
want to enable him
there you go and here's the thing he's
he's blessed to have somebody like you
that cares about him
and sounds like your new husband's a
saint too good for him
i've met a number of new husbands second
husbands over the years that don't want
anything to do with their spouses adult
kids and so good for him
and here's what i think is going to make
the whole week
much better and that is you s sitting
down
and writing these out for yourself and
then calling your son
and then just letting your son know i
want to set up
the best week possible for all of us
you tell me all the time you're an
alcoholic i want to know
how long you can go without drinking
because i'm going to take the alcohol to
the house i want us to have a fun
connected sober time and be ready
angela for him to blow his top and to
throw a temper tantrum and be mad
and say you're not getting rid of all
the alcohol it's going to be a terrible
thanksgiving or i don't want you to have
to do all that
he might do that and if he does he does
hopefully he doesn't hopefully he says
wow that's awesome my parents love me
and they care about me
and you know that's a long stretch for a
true alcoholic
and maybe he's just running his mouth a
little bit about being an alcoholic he
may be
he likes to drink he likes to drink this
old man but he he
may be just fine going a week right but
i think the the true
adult integris thing to do is to call
him on the front end and set up the
ground rules whatever they may be
and letting him know hey i'm taking all
the booze out of the house
yeah he's been pretty pretty good at
understanding
um i you know i have not given him any
money for
almost a year now i'm not enabling him
like i was
and he he actually accepts that
and we have a good relationship so it's
awesome
i feel like he'll understand why i'm
doing it because i
i do use uh i love you too much to it's
that's too painful
for me i'm not the adult child of an
alcoholic i had an alcoholic ex-husband
now i have an alcoholic son that's right
so i know i can be over
sensitive and i need to watch myself
about
setting boundaries in a kind of
organized non-emotional way
there you go and let's understood it let
your new husband
let him know that this is hard for you i
know you already have but let him know
hey i'm going to set some boundaries
down and
people who are true addicts they will
hear you intellectually
but emotionally they will they will say
things to you and they will fight you
and they will kick you
not not physically but they will fight
and kick and scream
because their their inner child is
hurting out it's hurting right it's
yelling yeah
so set those boundaries feel good about
them
understand that you're caring about him
but do the next
right hard thing which is to let him
know ahead of time
and understand that anytime you set up a
boundary there is a chance
that other people respond poorly to that
boundary and he may throw a temper
tantrum and not come
he may say if you're gonna do all this
and i'm just gonna stay here with dad
and your whole week's going to be blown
and you're going to call and you're
going to say deloney you
told me to call him and i wish i hadn't
cause this sucks
and he didn't show up and i'm going to
be sad with you
but it still would be the right thing to
do
letting him know hey you can't come to
my house drunk if you leave my house if
you sneak booze into my house
i'm going to ask you to leave we're
going to have an alcohol-free week i
want to set us
all up to be successful and if you can't
go that long i totally understand i love
you
let's only let's only spend three or
four days together
good for you angela i appreciate you
trying no matter how old your son gets
you know he's almost 30. you're still
trying to figure out ways to love him
you're still trying to figure out ways
to no longer empower him
good for you and you also recognize the
one
heartbreaking thing about addiction and
loved ones
is that they have to choose we can't do
it for them
we can't make other people get well and
that sucks
so it makes us feel powerless right but
thank you so much angela for the call
let me know how it goes i want to know
how the thanksgiving holiday goes
man we will be rooting for you